so i want to share with you some pretty
surprising gmo foods that you
may have never heard about
but before i do i want to share
something with you this morning when i
have my breakfast
um
i always like to read labels so i
noticed that
this product had 2 grams of fat per
serving size which is incredible but
good thing it had zero cholesterol but
if you scroll down
it has this very interesting new term i
want to share with you it says contains
bioengineered food ingredients i don't
know if you can see that probably can't
see that
bio-engineered food ingredients what the
heck is that all about so the definition
of bio-engineered food ingredients
is this
food that contains detectable
genetic material that has been modified
through certain lab techniques
that cannot be created through
conventional breeding or found in nature
now a few years ago food manufacturing
companies
were a little concerned that gmos were
going to be labeled
on their products because vermont in a
few other states passed laws
that now had to label products with gmos
and just so you know gmos are basically
foods that they've altered the dna
genetics and food manufacturing
companies were concerned that
more and more states
would legalize or pass laws
to reveal what foods were genetically
modified versus which ones weren't so
they had a very very bright idea
they came up with a new term called
bioengineered ingredients it sounds
different than gmo foods the branding
shows this wonderful sun
on these great crops with this little
plant growing so it it seems very very
safe and healthy but basically
bioengineer products are another name
for gmos it pretty much bypassed the gmo
labeling
problem that they had now if we again
look a little closer at the definition
of bioengineered food ingredients
it says food that contains detectable
genetic
material
okay detectable
here's the problem when you process the
food especially when you alter process
the food like in 70 percent of all the
refined foods out there
this genetic material
falls below the radar gmos are not
detectable in some of these really ultra
fine products because they're using
chemicals and high heat and pressure
and solvents to basically break down
these gmo products so small that they're
undetected
so what does that mean it means that
if the more processing you do to a
product the more you can get rid of the
traces of gmo so they don't have to be
labeled as bio-engineered food
ingredients whereas if they had gmo
labeling
if they came from a gmo product they
would have to put it on the label
so it's actually an ingenious way
to hide gmo in products below the radar
and on top of that these companies don't
even have to use the term bioengineered
food ingredients they can instead they
can use either a qr code that little
barcode that gives a lot more
information about product that little
code that you have to scan with your
cell phone or a phone number that you'd
have to call to get more information
if this product was bio-engineered or
not so the question is who has time to
scan this barcode or call the number and
most customers probably 99 of all
customers don't have a clue of what the
term bio-engineered food ingredients
really it means
and so now you know what it means and i
really appreciate if you can spread this
video to your friends and family far and
wide so more and more people can
understand what this new term is
all right let's go
back to the main reason for this video
which are surprising gmo foods that you
may be eating that you may want to
consider not eating all right number one
yellow squash okay
that is gmo now realize if you're having
organic yellow squash
it's not going to be gmo all right
number two beets
like the vast majority of beets
especially in the u.s
probably 95 percent of them are gmo and
that is where we're getting our sugar
from as well so if something says sugar
on the label
chances are it's from beets and chances
are it is gmo sugar all right number
three papaya is gmo number four eggplant
is gmo unless it says non-gmo or organic
all right number five green zucchini is
gmo right unless it says organic and
number six certain apples are gmo and
number seven
which is
most surprising
salmon is gmo now if it says wild caught
salmon
it's not going to be gmo but certain
farm-raised salmon is gmo so this is
just another reason why to
choose organic if possible but if you
don't have organic available
at least at the bare minimum do the
non-gmo but there's some real
interesting information about what
non-gmo really means and i put that
video up right here check it out
you